Український уряд стверджує,
що до 2020 року
Україна зможе відмовитися
від імпорту газу
і навіть продавати власне блакитне паливо
іншим країнам.
DW вирішила розібратися, що для цього потрібно.
З технічної точки зору
можливість газової незалежності України -
не утопія, вважають опитані DW як українські,
так і німецькі газові експерти.
Нині українці споживають 30 мільярдів кубометрів
газу на рік. З них 66 відсотків країна видобуває
на своїх родовищах, решту отримує реверсом з країн ЄС.
Тож для досягнення енергетичної незалежності
Україна повинна збільшити
видобуток газу на третину.
У вересні минулого року
Кабмін схвалив Стратегію сталого розвитку
"Україна-2020",
що передбачає нарощення видобутку газу
до 20-ти мільярдів кубометрів
держкомпанією "Укргазвидобуток"
та ще семи мільярдів - приватним сектором.
Це справді реально у найближчі 3-5 років,
якщо інвестувати у це понад три мільярди доларів,
вважають газові експерти.
Досягти таких показників можна лише за умови,
що вдасться подолати корупцію
та зарегульованість у цій галузі,
а також вирішити проблему олігархічного впливу.
Усе це полегшило б життя
українському бізнесу, а також дало б змогу
залучити міжнародні інвестиції.
Проте відповідні закони,
передбачені Стратегією-2020,
вже рік припадають пилом у Верховній Раді
й не виносяться на голосування.